timmi Bruce is a radio host and
president independent woman's voice she
joins us tonight Amy thanks a lot for
coming on
well it's I've never said this it worked
at Fox for ten years I've never said
this on the air but I've thought it the
whole time you've got one channel that
disagrees with all the other channels
you have an island of dissent in the
middle of a sea of sameness and that's
too much for them and I wonder if we've
been lying to ourselves about the extent
to which they would like to shut this
channel down I don't think so
what you've described in your commentary
is totalitarianism we've seen it unfold
it is in fact part of why I left the
left my first book it's called the new
thought police warning about this
trajectory that the use of the
complaining about words or opinions was
beyond the conversations that we
normally have it was being designed and
the environment was being designed to be
able to destroy people now I love coming
on this show
I am honored and proud to be a part of
Fox News specifically for what you
discussed I've never been told what to
say I've never been told what not to say
I've never been removed because of the
presumption of what my opinion would be
you and I will disagree and have and we
disagree on many issues yes we will take
issue with each other we even will
disappoint each other on occasion but
what we embody here is that we care
about each other we will have those
conversations and we will be able to
have them about other people and have
that exchange
what's manifesting here is a desire to
shut that down across the board
and if the left thinks that that's a
monster that they're going to be able to
control and just aim at us they're going
to be very surprised when that monster
gets out of its bottle and begins to
move amongst all of them and this is
what I think is a problem for that for
society in general and for the larger
effort about being able to have these
conversations become a better nation and
become better people and embrace
ourselves and the First Amendment
especially when it's difficult so I
don't really understand the mindset that
leads to one you see it on display and
the other
even now to want to shut down people at
disagree I grew up in a world where
magazines were important and you had
national review in the American you know
the American Spectator and then you had
the nation and Mother Jones and Village
Voice sure it never occurred to me to
want to shut the other side down why
would they want to stop all dissent
what's the point of that well part of
what I had a hand in and when I still
work on making up for in in these years
is this design of individuals who we
really couldn't argue the details of the
issues we we couldn't really persuade
people on the issues and the way then
and we've seen of course it's not just
the American left but the left around
the world the only way that the Left can
survive is by shutting down dissent
literally and eliminating the
individuals whose might speak up even
just with a different idea the idea as
you've noted on the issue of conformity
any voice or any individual that is a
reminder that we can approach things
differently and sometimes offend people
and sometimes make mistakes and as you
said apologize but the difference is is
that the left can't withstand an
environment where there's any
challenging because they rely on the
collective they don't rely on ideas they
rely on fear and division and
controlling people within that framework
you see it unfolding of course still in
Venezuela in Cuba it was the collapse of
the Soviet Union it's that it's it's the
antithesis to individual personal
freedom which involves the the need to
have larger conversations to be able to
speak our mind without fear and without
being bullied or threatened because we
might deviate from what the left deems
to be a proper and pure thought we're
all a set a time but I just want to know
if you if you think it's right that
Republicans in Washington some of our
leaders people who should be standing up
for the other side for the other view
seem terrified to stray outside the
lines
well they've been set down by their
enemies look it our society social media
there's a lot of great stuff about
social media but there is a
concentration of rage that very often is
contrived it
manipulated and managed politically and
on social media it suddenly seems like
it's organic but it's not and it
frightens politicians who think that
that's a real reflection of real life
look people are genuinely and got
involved and engaged in the things that
matter in our lives as a feminist it
matters to me how we're all portrayed
but at the same time we've got to have
freedom of thought and freedom of
expression and we have a role in that
and so do the politicians they've got to
feel strong enough and free enough that
they can speak their minds and stand up
for what's right Jaime Bruce an
old-fashioned liberal and I mean that is
a compliment great thank you thank you
thank you Tucker